I'm a cadaver commenced on my balloon
hey we're doing another movie review
yeah American Werewolf in love an
American Werewolf in London this is
really good because I had seen this
movie it came out in 1981 when I was 9
years old yeah I had never seen it and
yeah and Tommy I'd never seen it like I
had seen it a bunch of times but I
hadn't seen it for many years and then I
was scrolling through Netflix the other
night and I noticed that they had it and
I was like oh man I totally forgot about
that yeah we should totally do this
movie especially because you had never
seen it yet now the movie was directed
by John Landis and it was actually it's
kind of for a comedy than a horror movie
I guess even though it's pretty gory and
you know it's a werewolf movie obviously
yeah but you know John Landis up until
that point had mostly been known for
comedies obviously he did Animal House
and he did Kentucky Fried movie
yeah there's humor in it but I wouldn't
call it a comedy per se but I think I
think the humor that's in it does kind
of add a new element to a horror movie
yes it's pretty good like there are some
comedy cores that are just saying you
know like army of Darkness and things
like yeah yeah it's not like that it's
like an additional seventies horror
movie with just some funny parts and
with cutting-edge 80s makeup well I feel
like an American Werewolf in London was
really kind of a landmark yeah movie
like an 80s horror
yeah the transformation scenes were good
I mean still impressive for today you
know those tricks now but still is
effective yeah now like I said the movie
came out 1981 although John Landis had
the idea for it back in 1970 when he was
working on the crew of Kelly's heroes
now evidently while he was filming
Kelly's heroes he was in what was then
Yugoslavia and the story goes that him
and another guy on the crew saw these
gypsies and they were burying a guy in
the cemetery and they were burying him
feet-first like all the way down and
then you know Cinna so he wouldn't come
back like as the undead or whatever and
evidently this is the story told and
this kind of fascinated him so he kind
of wrote you know he wrote a script
about a werewolf and stuff and he kind
of shopped it around but he couldn't get
it made for a really long time because
everyone thought it was too weird or
nobody made werewolf movies anymore
or anything like that so then he went on
and made you know several other comedies
like I said he made animal house and he
made Blues Brothers and stuff like that
those were very successful so finally he
kind of got the funds to make it and
it's funny because it's pretty much as
soon as that came out and this did not
happen on purpose really but as soon as
it came out a bunch of other werewolf
movies kind of came out around the same
as wolfin and the howling and stuff like
those yes and didn't even Stephen King
did psycho on the world for whatever the
[ __ ] up the movie was shitty it was
one of the quarries wasn't it Corey Haim
or something like that but it was kind
of remember it being short like this
right oh yeah it wasn't that it was all
right this is about the time of Salem's
Lot actually which is made for TV that
was awesome - yeah yeah but you know
okay so American Werewolf in London
basically stars David Naughton who had
been in the dr. pepper commercials I
think that was all he had been in I
don't know you don't remember the dr.
pepper don't remember yet okay so that's
that's who he was I don't think he had
been at any movies prior to that or had
only had bit parts but he had the main
part in this and it was there also
griffin dunne and also Jenny Agutter
from Logan's Run with her I reviewed
before she played the nurse okay so the
funny thing okay so these two guys are
college guys and they're backpacking
around Europe like you do well if you
get for it I certainly couldn't but uh
so yeah so they're backpacking around
Europe be in college guys blah blah blah
now they get lost well they don't really
get lost but they're out on the moors
yes and even though it's supposed to be
kind of the north of England although it
was actually filmed in Wales which I
kind of knew when I looked at it but so
they end up at this pub and there are
all these really stereotypical crabby
old pub guys that are like looking at
them askance and stuff like that what
they've gone backwards in time yeah it's
funny because one of those guys I don't
know if you guys know this but one of
the guys in the pub one of the younger
guys is actually Rik Mayall who actually
got very famous later on for being on
The Young Ones yeah ed on bottom and a
bunch of other stuff sadly passed away a
few years ago but this was one of his
first roles so they noticed while
they're in this pub that there's you
know like a red satanic looking symbol
that's drawn on the wall yeah and so
it's a pet
pedicle yeah so for some reason they get
like super interested about what that
means that they just can't stop
themselves from asking the locals what
it is yeah they're Jewish kids they
don't know yeah but yeah so they ask it
obviously you know if there had been a
record player in the pub it would have
been like a record scratch and you know
the people I know it's it's not that
it's just been there a lot you know
basically they give them the cold
shoulder and stuff then there it seems
like some of the locals are like well
when they leave the pub the lady that
runs the pub is kind of like you can't
just let them go out there thank you you
know the thing that is going on audience
already audience member you already know
that there's a werewolf well the movie
is called it about yeah so you know
there's a werewolf they go out there
yeah yeah so they have a big argument
and stuff and meanwhile this part is
actually kind of funny because the two
guys they kind of you know they're named
David and Jack alphas I think I forgot
to mention that so they go out of the
Moors
and the people told them you know kind
of stay off the moor stay on the road
you'll be fine that's a werewolf
kinosaki oh girl the road yeah I guess
werewolves don't like that stay on the
road yeah which predictably they do not
because they give me something about the
moon - would they say keep your eye on
the moon keep your eye on the moon stay
on the road
yeah I think they so predictably about
five seconds after they leave the pub
one - get lost - they're so busy like
shooting the [ __ ] with each other that
they wander off the road until they
watch no they were trying to watch the
moon and they get attacked by worms this
is actually a very good sequence because
you don't really see the werewolf you
just hear these growls and you can't
really tell where they're coming from
and then they're kind of getting closer
kind of getting farther away and they
don't really know where they're going so
they're kind of running and they're like
where is it where is it and then this
big animal comes and takes Jack out her
friend Don's character he gets killed
kills him early yeah so yeah he gets
killed like in the first 10 minutes of
the movie then there's a gunshot because
David gets attacked - he gives me good
but he lives and he gets bitten the pop
guys I guess decided to come and help
them a little bit too late yeah they
basically had to rescue him and they
shot the damn where
I shot the werewolf but then David looks
over and sees a man and sees a naked man
that has it had transformed back into a
man like you do if you're a werewolf you
turn back no he was bitten by a werewolf
yeah so then you next see David and he's
been taken to London to a hospital and
he's been out for three weeks which
means it'll be the full moon again soon
so evidently in the town where the
werewolf attack happened
they basically when they had the police
come and everything like that they just
told him when he was just attacked by a
crazy guy and yeah and Jack got killed
and all this other stuff so David is
insisting he's like no we got attacked
by an animal it was like a big dog or
like a rabid dog or something like that
to me all the werewolves the upper
bodies were wide I guess kind of a human
shoulders well yeah they wanted to make
it look like a muscular man right to me
it looked a little but with a wiry
bottom and wolfy head to me it looked a
little bit like a cartoon drawing of a
wild wild boar it did look cool I guess
yeah you know didn't have a dog profile
do you know what werewolf movie you
would probably like is Dog Soldiers
have you ever seen that uh it's a
British werewolf movie it's very good I
recommend it if you haven't seen even if
you're into werewolves is what was that
one wolf a wolf in yeah yeah I remember
wolfen scaring the [ __ ] movie when I was
little yeah you don't see it you just
see it from the eyes of the wolf yeah
which in a lot of horror movies like if
you don't have the money to show [ __ ]
it's probably better to just like keep
it kind of shared is it scarier and
there was a cat people were just kind of
like that - well see cat that was a
remake of a movie from the 40s actually
I kind of liked them the forties ones
better we're getting it I thought it was
paper but yeah so yeah so David wakes up
in the hospital and he's insistent now
one of the cops doesn't really believe
him but then kind of does because he
keeps it you know obviously he's upset
that his friend and it has died and
stuff like that but he's not so upset
that he can't start putting the moves on
Jenny Agutter who plays the nurse that's
taken care of
she kind of put the moves on
she did kind of yet she kind of started
they kind of put moves on each other
yeah now while he's still in the
hospital his dead friend Jack starts
showing up yeah and he's all [ __ ] up
like they when you first see him like I
think most most his face got his throats
all torn out and [ __ ] like that but the
funny thing about it and actually john
landis told griffin dunne
he said now every time you turn up in
the movie as an undead person you have
to be like in the best mood ever cuz for
some reason he thought the juxtaposition
would be very funny which it is so every
time you see griffin dunne and you see
him like three or four times in the
course of the movie and he gets like
more and more decayed and [ __ ] up
Jonah he's showing up in public so you
obviously know that he's hallucinating
this guy yeah well even though he is
hallucinating him what griffin dunne
says is it will jack his new character's
name is jack what jack says is that okay
well I'm here I got killed by a werewolf
you got bit by a werewolf that means on
the next full moon you're going to turn
into a werewolf and kill people so you
need to kill yourself right he's like
because everyone who gets bit by the
whale for it gets killed by the werewolf
is doomed to walk the earth as an undead
just like jack is okay so the werewolf
slime has to end right so basically what
Jack is coming back to say is that david
has to kill himself before he kills
other people who will then be cursed the
way he is cursed right obviously David
does not believe this right he just
thinks he's going nuts you know he went
through some trauma and he's just seeing
a hallucination of his dead friend so he
is subsequently released from the
hospital and the nurse like you know she
lets him stay at her flat because I
don't know like at one point at what
point David was supposed to go back home
or whatever but I guess he was he was
gonna go on to Italy after England they
were going to so he was gonna be over
there for a while so he goes and stays
at her flat and you know they kind of
start hooking up and everything like
that
then Jack appears to him to in her
apartment now if she had come out to the
room earlier I don't know if she could
have seen him I don't think so because I
think in a couple times he was in the
street and I don't remember anyone else
seeing him because he looked pretty
messed up yeah like the second time we
go yeah the second time he showed up in
her apartment he was like all green
right
indicated look in a jet and you know
he's like okay for real you were gonna
turn into a werewolf like tomorrow night
you had better do something about that
the next day nurse goes back to work and
in the meantime what did the main doctor
that had taken care of David's case yeah
he starts getting G's he starts getting
kind of in trees like you know maybe he
was attacked by a rabid dog or something
like that and the and the townspeople
were like covering up because they
seemed a little secretive he ends up
thinking that it's a werewolf yeah so he
actually goes to the town and he goes to
the pub where they were last seen and
everybody in the pub is like I don't
know what you're talking about those two
kids weren't ever hear about what and
he's like okay yeah so but then on the
way out like this other guy who had been
in the pub that night he comes out and
he's like I don't think he specifically
says the word werewolf but he's like you
know that guy is in danger you know he's
gonna kill people and all this other
stuff where he says something to that
effect so I think the doctor does start
to believe that there's I don't know if
he necessarily thinks it's a werewolf
but he thinks there's something weird
going on so the next day the nurse goes
to work and while she's gone David
starts getting real antsy like sort of
pacing around the apartment and stuff
like that he hasn't everywhere to go
then the evening comes and here is the
centerpiece of the entire film the
transformation sequence which still
looks good this was 1981 yeah all them
with practical effects and John Landis
specifically said you know he talked to
Rick Baker who obviously you know big
makeup guy probably the most famous one
of the day and he said you know I've
seen all these old werewolf movies where
they do like these kind of crossfades
and or they'll do it in the shadow he's
like I don't know if this can be done
but he's like I want the werewolf to
transform in broad daylight right in
front of you and he's and he's like and
I want it to look like it hurts yeah it
looks good it really does so I mean you
know it's that you know it's a it's a
prosthetic so you know it's mechanical
house not totally convincing it's not
convincing but it looks good it really
does yeah I mean I my favorite thing is
when he puts up his hand and the fingers
like stretch hair starts coming out the
hairs are popping out in his face link
and like I said that was all done
mechanically with various yeah it's it
looks really good really one of my
favorite parts is remember when he
starts having visions it's actually a
dream of a bunch of Nazi not a werewolf
coming into the house shooting ad with
Mac tans and their helmet so yeah
there's a lot of really cool scenes in
it which in a lot of ways and I think
I've read this in a couple of rows it
didn't really occur to me while I was
watching it even though you know he had
the Nazi dream and and even though one
of the other nurses makes the comment
about David being a Jew because she had
a peek yeah which is weird because a lot
of people are circumcised now so you
can't really tell but that by that
anymore but it was 1981 but I have seen
that junkie there's a British thing yeah
but I have seen that John Landis that he
could have written this as sort of like
a metaphor not necessarily a metaphor
but something like him David being
Jewish is like being an outsider
particularly as he was already an
outsider in a foreign country he was an
American and he was in Britain and you
know there was some kind of
misunderstood cultural misunderstandings
and things like that but I think he kind
of played off the idea of the Jew being
the other now it was like really another
he's a monster he's a werewolf you know
what I mean and his his idea of monsters
are not only werewolves but Nazi
werewolves that's pretty cool yeah so
yeah there was a wiki had that dream
sequence where the Nazi werewolves came
to the door so yeah I have like read
that and you could see it is that even
though there was only really a couple of
mentions but as it happens you know
David obviously transforms into a wolf
he kills a bunch of people I think he
kills six people like the first night
he's a werewolf and he doesn't remember
it but he wakes up the next morning in
the wolf enclosure at the zoo yeah but
yeah so eventually it seems like the the
following day like as soon as he wakes
up and gets his [ __ ] together and goes
back to the nurses apartment
soon as he hears about these six murders
that have taken place around the city he
knows that it was him right it's nice to
get arrested yeah well yeah he's like
those and yells at the cop and he's like
me arrest me and he's destroyed the
Queen's ax or he's like starts insulting
the Queen and all of a sudden yeah stuff
but they don't arrest him
no hey let's go so actually my favorite
part of the movie one of my favorite
parts other than the transformation
scene was the last time that Jack shows
up yeah and he's like super rotten and
he shows up outside of a porn theater
yeah and it and like calls David it's
like hey come in here this is a Wesen
porn okay now here's a funny thing the
porn movie within the movie which is
called see you next Wednesday instead of
the obvious see you next Tuesday cont
but he thought it would be funnier if it
was see you next Wednesday John Landis
actually filmed that too he filmed like
a large portion of a porn movie and that
girl that was in it she was a page three
girl which if you're British you'll know
what that is like those ladies that
appear topless on page three of The
Daily Mirror I want to say I'm not sure
if that's what it is but um one of the
tabloids and she actually went on to a
porn career later on so I guess yeah so
why the hell would grown men going to a
porn theater watch more well you
couldn't it's not like now where you can
just see it on the internet or even you
could just write no weird
I would you know what I was all sticky
that's what I mean I would hate to have
worked in there he's like having to mop
it up yeah man all these dudes just
sitting and [ __ ] pee-wee Herman got
busted for that like jerking off and
report and that was like much after I
mean there's really after the 80s after
the home video boom there's really no
excuse for that more to that we'll see I
think that was kind of more I think guys
that went there almost had like a little
bit of homoeroticism that exhibition is
amazing but yeah it does seem like weird
to sit in a theater with a bunch of
dudes and not in the good way yeah so um
so yeah so they're sitting in the back
of the porn theater and now not only can
David see Jack but he also sees all the
other people that you know
who are now also person is like Jack
said yeah so at this point it seems like
David kind of tries to do the right
thing and kill himself but he can't
bring himself to do it you know well I
don't necessarily want to spoil the
ending even though it is a little abrupt
yeah one thing about this movie is that
in many ways seems like a 70s movies and
in other ways it seems like an 80s movie
they don't quite have the 80's horror
formula yet yeah what happened in the
80s you'd have this big ending where the
monster was killed and then it would
come back that you have to kill it again
yeah that wasn't around yet at this
thankfully cuz now it's been done it's
been done something happens you know you
have to kill a monster twice at least
yeah possibly three times in this one
they just kind of kill the monster
there's not a lot to it well yeah
because it's in the stator and climactic
I thought while he's still in the porn
theater he turns into a werewolf again
he starts rampaging around he's right
everybody kills much people but then
they just kill the monster yeah and the
way that ends it seems very abrupt
yeah and unnatural by today's standards
because we're so used to that you kill
the monster but then the monster comes
back you have to kill again there's a
long yeah they have to build up and it's
like deal so I can see how in a way I
don't know it's like it's it's weird
thing to say about a movie that was made
1981 but in a way it's kind of like
refreshing because that trope hadn't
been established you alright so in a way
the ending was a lot more as realistic
as a room the ending of a werewolf movie
could be kind of like the ending of Jaws
you only killed jaws once yeah you shot
the barrel and he just blew up right so
you know little pieces of them didn't
get back on it was like that yeah so
like I said it was a lot more realistic
because if somebody actually did turn
into a werewolf in the middle of London
that's exactly what would happen is he
start running around it but it was shoot
him yeah and then he just be dead yeah
and obviously I mean I don't think that
he didn't really use the trope about
silver bullets and all this cuz
obviously they just shot him with
regular bullets and yeah it's a good
movie it is yeah and like I said I feel
like it's kind of like the bridge
between like you said like maybe 70s
movies in 80's movies yeah yeah yeah
and it's funny because being from 1981
the special effects in that were were a
lot better than movies that came a lot
later it had the creepiness of a 70s
movie yeah but it had the special
effects of an 80s movies and like you
said it's considered a horror comedy
it's not a zany no as some other horror
comedies like it's not like what was the
one we watch the Tucker and Dale vs.
evil witch which is actually really good
which is a more straight it's very very
gory but it's also like a pretty much a
straight comedy just gore in it or you
know like Shaun of the Dead or something
like that which cat was kind of a
combination so it's not as funny as that
it was kind of more like subtle humor
black humor I can restrain I can
remember when this movie came out yeah
all right and people liked it then yeah
people that were older than me they're
going to go see it yeah people in there
teenagers and early twice but today does
it hold up it's I think it falls into
the same category as vampires vampires
and werewolves are about the same witch
yeah I think they've been around for so
long that they're not that scary you
know what's gonna happen in a vampire
movie yeah it's time I enjoy like wall
truly and this is kind of the doesn't
compare to see like the thing the thing
had body [ __ ] yeah know what could
happen yeah I mean and I and I feel like
that's true of a lot of horror movies I
think I like traditional kind of monster
movies to an extent if they're done well
but if I'm gonna I don't find them scary
though I do enjoy them like you know for
the gore for the just the story or
whatever but if I'm going to find
something scary it's going to be either
a ghost story yeah or it's going to be
like an unknown type of thing or
something that isn't established I like
the movie I appreciated it I didn't find
it scary at all no it's not it's not a
scary movie like I said it had a couple
good like tense scenes but on the whole
it's a low-key comedy slash gory horror
movie that's worth saying though and
yeah and by today's standards it might
be considered a little slow there's a
lot of buildup there's a lot of
characterization and then there's like
short bursts of like gore and attacks I
mean when he busts out of the porn
theater at the end and like with all the
car accidents and heads flying off
anything like that
you know but there's only a few of those
right like most of the time in between
but but in a way it's kind of good
because I like that they build up I like
that they build up the relationship
between him and the dead guy because the
conversations with him and the dead guy
like with Jack are really funny right
like because you can tell that they're
you know that they've been best friends
for a long time and the absurdity of the
situation triol II believe that he's
really seeing him and stuff like that so
I like that about it and a lot of time
is spent building up the relationship
between him and the nurse and stuff like
that so like I said by today's standards
might be a little slow it's not relaxed
I think it was by the standards of that
day also because I had already seen
alien 1 by this time and had I saw this
when this came out alien would have
outclassed easily alien scared the hell
out of me
alien emphasized cemani not alien was a
very scary movie but like we were saying
before alien was you that was kind of
like the unknown you would never see
anything like that right so you didn't
know what that monster could do never
being a kid and coming across like what
was the name of that magazine Fangoria
yeah yeah yeah an infant gory a magazine
it would have photos of things from
American Werewolf in London and alien in
the same magazine and it just didn't
compare I'd see that I didn't really
want to see the werewolf movie that
maybe I'd see alien already maybe like
oh man I remember one that I wonder what
dad meant wow what was that alien ship
where'd that come from it was Gary yeah
it was weird though how in the 80s there
seemed like kind of a there was there
was kind of like all the alien and
sci-fi stuff going on and then there was
almost a throwback to like traditional
University yeah it's all having the same
time yes mr. werewolf movies it was a
bunch of vampire movies well this movie
it was a British movie made in England
so I'm it was made in England you know
the directors America it's gonna be a
little more old-school I think because
they were making stuff it's kind of an
old-school ways yeah that's true anymore
Matt yeah oh and also I wanted to
mention you remember the scene near the
beginning where the America guy from the
American Embassy comes in that rules
don't Deb is she looking odd you know
maybe that was is it Frank Oz from the
Muppets he was the guy that did Fozzie
Bear and Miss Piggy and so if anything
they are real American yeah I was first
acting like I found that out later it's
like I didn't realize at the time
because you think I would have
recognized his voice I was thinking man
that guy's ex it's horrible maybe he was
trying to disguise his voice so he
wouldn't sound like a muppet maybe
because I can't remember I can't
remember offhand what his dad she can
make good movies though you know I mean
Star Wars actually was a British movie
largely yes most of the career was
rushed well and they filmed it over
there and well honestly here's and we
were talking about this the other day
too because we were talking about about
that guy in this movie I was like it's
funny how American actors have a really
hard time doing a British accent I'm
looking at you Keanu Reeves in Francis
Ford Coppola terrible and why not a
writer didn't really do it that great
either I can pass it on but British
people can pass as Americans largely do
you know like I think we had watched two
or three seasons of The Walking Dead
before I really did check the plays
Maggie is British yeah but at least the
Dixons were we're a real redneck yeah
you know you had to have some but I met
but I never would have known that in a
million years because I never said I
know when you was in love actually that
British but I don't that's a chick flick
I don't usually see most of those so I
didn't know about that but so anyway
uh like I wrap this up yeah Oh a
somewhat I mention - before we wrap it
up the this movie actually American
Werewolf in London actually won the
first ever Academy Award for makeup okay
yeah this was the first artist yet for
the transformation scene because
obviously it wouldn't seen anything like
that so anyway we're gonna wrap this up
and get back to our hurricane
preparation yeah so hope you guys
enjoyed this review of American world in
London we will be putting more movie
reviews up when we can hopefully it will
be soon hopefully we won't blow it and
hopefully we won't blow away well in
history right off the coast of us yeah
yeah we'll see so if we're still here
keep on watching and we'll keep putting
shows up and until next time right
[Music]
[Music]
you